[音楽]
凧揚げです1回普通に飛ばすみます
僕は
あっ挟む50パーファー
あああああああ
あっはウ
っていうたこ揚げがあるんですけども凧揚げ皆さんしたことありますでしょうか
僕は多分ないです食べないんですけど今何か普通にやってみたら結構上がって楽しかっ
たんですけど
あくあげってこの日も猫ヒュッテたこ上はで飛ばして女か
うわぁ凄いねすごいねって見るだけなんですけどこの人ってどれくらいなんだろう
サイズ書いてないんちょっと上がってみましょう紐の長さはどれくらい
確かめてみましょうん
[音楽]
方が下がります
me
goo ん
[音楽]
はいだいたいですねヨンジュン2m ぐらいですはいてゆけで紐の長さが4図2
メートルくらいあることが分かりましたで今回ちょっと僕が試したいのは凧揚げって
どれくらい高く飛ぶんじゃねっていうところ既存の凧揚げだと4寸2メートルが限界で
そしてへともっと上に行くために日も全部しました
450m
でなく行けば最大高さ500メートルまで凧が揚がります
また日本の領空持ってるっけあ領空に決まったコードは定義されてないんだっていうも
のってことはまあ100キロぐらいまで高さの大丈夫の多分500m ぐらい大丈夫だ
と思いますまずはとりあえずこのタコで42m 飛ぶかどうか試していきましょう
米が読まず10m ぐらいあげてみます
いきます
a 4 a 0 d 4いう
めっちゃすげー続けああ
言えず梅田以外は全然余裕です次は20m ぐらい行ってみましょう
結構20ってすごいよねいきます
goo
よやっ
よりやつ2
まあ
ができません
ん
[音楽]
[笑い]
30メートル入ったんですけど多分余裕過ぎますこのまま一気にあの
42メートルまで行っちゃいましたこんなまま書き上がってやんで
42メートルでもうめっちゃ高いんだな
[音楽]
なった稼ぎでやばいんだけどねまだまだいく
やばいやばいんじゃなくてもいいじゃないはいフィギュアさこれが42m です
全然そこでも
[音楽]
逢いたい理由だ4寸2メートル左右ですできてここからこの人にさらに良いとくっつけ
て何メートルまで飛ばせるか
ズッキしてみたいと思います待っておりねー
堀ねーなーこれおりねー
よし多分もう取れないと思います
合計500メートルの高さまでいけるような講義が完成しました
はいというわけであとはあっ
このた号
ランメートルまで上げる行ってきます
50m お湯ですさあ
[音楽]
ぱっちゅれー
アイゼンフリーまた分60年とためですもうちょい伸ばしてみましょう
あっはぁ
はヤバイん
[音楽]
迷い迷い奪い4位はいよいよ
を100いってねこれを言ってるね頭痛
100名とで来ましたあそこにあります今
病ねキックすごいですよここは
乳首物からデビューが先輩でもうちょいてますてみましょう105人
ん
まずはやばいかもへ
[音楽]
tue
me
ん
フェたーーーーなるやな
car
[音楽]
he
wh
then
おっつおっつまた急速に落ちちゃうヤバイん
わー
[音楽]
落ちちゃったっ